I shall begin.
So we're just looking at this virtue, parami, this perfection.
We'll come to that in a minute.
This word, the resolution, determination, adhitana.
So we've got lots of words.
Persistence, tenacity, perseverance, doggedness, resolve, resolution, steadfast, willpower, purpose, purposeful, grit.
And all these are life's little nuances to our understanding of determination.
So the word itself, Adi, it'd be split into Adi and Persistence.
Tana, Adi just means higher, above, superior, etc.
So you get it in words like Adichita, superior mind, or Adipati, who's a ruler.
Tana is used both in a realistic sense of place or location, but metaphorically, it's a state, a condition, a reason, occasion.
and uh most of you will know the um the sati patana sutta so the tana at the end is the establishment the foundation the part is just reinforcing that a deep and profound establishment of sati awareness and that's the discourse on how to establish awareness uh i i like the word perseverance for some reason you know just dogged perseverance
In the Visuddhimagga, it talks about the resolution to undertake and carry out the requisites of awakening without wavering.
It's an unwavering commitment, unshakable resolve.
It also talks about an unshakable resolve directed towards a wholesome goal, grounded in wisdom and supported by the other perfections.
So what we'll do is go through these perfections and show how Adhitana sort of is a binding force that brings them all together in order for us to attain a particular goal.
Of course, here we're centred on liberation, but these things also work for even, you know, making a relationship work, some task at work itself, anything that you undertake, which is going to take effort and continued effort.
All these factors come into play.
So if we just go through the power of me.
So generosity, you see.
So when you set yourself a goal on something, it's being generous to yourself, isn't it?
You're giving yourself something.
You're giving yourself an aim.
And because we are always interconnected, as you know, involving other people, it's also a gift for them.
So that generosity comes in there somewhere, the feeling of giving.
Now, when it comes to virtue, sila, ethical conduct, you can then see how if you don't have that, things can go a bit wrong.
So somebody I think who has clear determination is Putin.
I mean, he's prepared.
When I say that, he's prepared to put so many millions, so many thousands of young men at the front to be killed and wounded.
So it's not actually affecting him.
He's probably enjoying caviar.
so but at least he's he's got that determination to sacrifice everybody to that final aim of expanding the uh the russian federation and of course you'll see that in all of these authoritarians these tyrants uh yeah and we can point to other people too but we shall go into that
so it has to be in terms of our practice of becoming fully liberated then obviously we need to it needs to be virtuous now nekama renunciation consider we've just had a little baby in the family and um when you think about and i'm many of you will have had children so when you think about you know having a child that's that's a huge commitment and yeah and you have to have perseverance
I think it was Kabat-Zinn, who some of you will know, you know, all that stuff about mindfulness training.
He said bringing up children was like 18 years on retreat.
So that sort of complete, you know, devotion.
I mean, a baby is 24 hours, 24 hours, seven, you know, conditioning.
And you have to you have to give up something.
Yeah.
You have to give up what you, what you would normally have done, go to, you know, go to the pictures or, um, uh, whatever, however you amuse yourselves.
So it, it involves some level of renunciation.
Pana.
So it's wisdom, of course.
Um, it's got to be a certain, um, devotion to righteousness.
I'm thinking here of, um,
people who really spend an enormous amount of energy trying to get injustices corrected uh the one that comes to mind recently was the um for those of in the uk was this huge miscarriage of justice about the post office where the powers that be trusted this accounting software and it eventually ended up with 900 postmasters being dismissed and there were suicides
um and some went to jail completely completely miscarried justice and it was the actions of one man specif you know in particular alan bates who spent 20 years getting justice can you imagine that 20 years perseverance and um and that's the that's the sort of wisdom that that that the idea of you know for justice
now obviously that's going to take energy effort right don't confuse effort with um with perseverance perseverance is a mental state it's a mental attitude rather whereas effort is the energy you need both the physical and mental energy uh not having any of these can undermine the whole project and then of course there's patience you know like this man 20 years for heaven's sake um and to
you know, to actually have the patience and the willingness to endure.
That's important too.
And then we have satya, which is truthfulness.
It's really being honest about oneself, about one's capabilities.
Obviously, if you have an aim, which is, you know, beyond your capability, you just get burnout and disappointment.
You know, I mean, if I started thinking about becoming a professional footballer,
And I got the kit and I went training.
Turned up at clubs.
It might be that a good friend of mine might come to tell me that maybe I was being a bit misguided, not enough humility.
So there has to be that sense of real, being real about oneself.
There's method, of course, doing anything which is wholesome.
And here we're talking specifically about liberation.
It's obviously an act of loving kindness, an act of care towards ourselves.
And because it always involves other people, it therefore is an act of care towards others.
And then finally, this quality of upeka, which is equanimity.
So, you know, that's being able to bear with things, not to get caught up in disappointment, not to go berserk when something wonderful has happened, to keep that even keel, which of course reserves energy and helps us to be more narrowed in our focus when we want something.
so that's uh that you can see how once you've brought a certain sense of persistence a certain sense of commitment to something all these all your virtues come to support you um gratitude once once you uh think about the things that have been given us then the natural thing is to want to give back
so virtues always support each other in some way or other yeah whereas vices anger greed they cancel each other out you can't be you can't be angry and greedy at the same time even though it might feel like that there are two mental states that cancel each other out
So how much should we, you know, what should our determination be when it comes to this process of liberation?
So this is taken from a particular discourse where the Buddha describes the sort of ascetic practices that he did.
And he says, he starts off with this clear determination.
Let only my skin, sinews and bones remain.
And let my flesh and blood dry up.
I will not give up my effort so long as I have not attained what can be attained by human strength.
Now, this took him into those ascetic practices, like holding his breath for as long as he could, not eating, of course, almost starving himself to death.
And at some point he realized that this was over-efforting.
It was a wrong sort of perseverance.
and with that he leaves his companions if you remember and um and then he finds this lovely place uh sorry and then he remembers this occasion in his life which according to the academics is the only bit of biography you can actually believe where he remembers watching his father doing an opening plowing ceremony and he's a young kid
And you know how young kids get involved.
And he's totally involved in what his father's doing, drawn by curiosity, by interest.
And this not only changes his practice from trying to attain something, you know, liberation, trying to attain it, to investigating his condition.
And he realizes that when he was in that state, he was actually very happy.
And now we call these things, when I say now, it's been only fairly, fairly recent in the past five, maybe seven, ten years, that the whole thing about sutta jhanas has come to the fore.
So the old jhana was normally, they call them the visuddhimagga jhana, where you become completely absorbed and lose all touch with the surroundings.
I mean, they're beautiful, they're very enjoyable.
uh but there's not there's no insight in it whereas with these sutta jhanas they're much lighter you can still be aware of things but it has that quality of curiosity and so is a is a path to liberation and this is what he begins to practice and this is what he refers to when he talks about people doing jhana practice it's a supportive thing to your inquiry
So, you know, it was a case of him realizing this when all the other stuff that the ascetics were practicing had failed him.
There's a distinction to be made between that and willpower.
So willpower in that sense of total commitment, but it's a sort of narrow vision.
And you're not aware of the mountains and the chasms that are in your way.
And you keep collapsing and push and push and push.
And of course, it upsets everybody around you.
It's willpower business, right?
so you know from the reaction of people around you that you might be doing something which is ego-based you know pride-based uh rather than coming from that sense of humility and of reality you know like being real about oneself and real about the situation it's a that that often happens when we're practicing and we move into over-efforting
so uh that that's the point where the determination the perseverance has actually gone a bit wonky right normally in meditation if you're sitting and you do that the meditation just collapses you just can't do it for a while so um when adhitana this uh perseverance this uh resolution is is
is developed there there's always that clear understanding about what the goal is there's a moral integrity about it there's a consistent a consistency about your practice and about what you're devoted to and there's the ability to endure the ability to endure so and the buddha sort of uh reinforces this
When a bhikkhu, that means anybody who's listening, has resolution, has developed it and has made it his basis, now that's the ground of his practice, you might say, then he obtains the destruction of the taints.
These taints, the āśawa, they are sort of deep-seated mental defilements.
They include, well, there's four of them, just the craving, craving, the craving for existence, you know, wanting to live, which is understandable, but it's that sort of attachment to life.
Ignorance, ignorance about one's true identity.
That's the basic problem.
And sometimes wrong view is attached to those arsos, those taints.
They're also called cankers.
it's a bit odd a canker is some sort of uh white thing on your tongue isn't it that hurts I don't know so somebody's called them fermentations uh translators do have a good time I think so finally how do we actually you know develop this so it's the small resolutions that you make that you keep
that builds up the muscle of perseverance so all of us have experienced you know perhaps being on retreat or um on a zoom or something and you've made a resolution that you're going to sit every morning for half an hour 40 minutes one hour whatever it is and it works for two or three days
and then it all shrinks, it becomes 25 minutes and then 20 minutes and then it just all disappears, you know, and you wonder what's happening.
So this is a lack of that resolution, a lack of that persistence, right?
That perseverance.
So one reestablishes it, right?
And to establish a habit, you've got to sort of put some energy into it, some commitment, and you must do it religiously for three months.
And then it becomes ingrained, right?
Not to say that we don't get lazy again and we lose it and we have to start all over again.
But that's the purpose of resolutions throughout the day.
Sometimes, you know, and I've made this mistake myself, you make a resolution to help somebody.
and you you've done it without real reflection so i remember once a friend of mine said he was moving into a new flat and he was gonna he's gonna decorate on the weekend and i just blurted out oh i'll come and help you see well come saturday morning the last thing i wanted to do was was decorate his apartment uh but i i i was good i was very good i i i determined to go and i went and helped him out for for the morning anyway
So sometimes we have to be careful what we resolve.
It's a bit like being careful what you wish for.
And to sort of praise ourselves when we've actually, you know, completed something which has taken a little bit of endurance.
Often, I don't think we congratulate ourselves enough.
We don't have that sort of self-love, that self-praise.
There's nothing wrong with that, as long as it doesn't get into an ego and how wonderful I am.
But when we complete a task, we should stop and just say, oh, that was good.
You know, I did good.
And in that vein, it's good to remember past times when we persevered with something and achieved something.
and that builds up confidence we can do you see and so to uh to to to end this off there's always these little phrases that uh arahat seem to say when when somebody seems to say when they become fully liberated and one of them is a lovely little thing it just says what had to be done has been done and you can imagine the relief
of being able to say that, right?
So we set ourselves a task, we commit ourselves to it, we resolve to complete the task, save, you always have to have a little, you know, a small print, yeah?
Save in emergency or extraordinary circumstance.
And you complete it and then you can say to yourself, what had to be done has been done.
And you get that sense of deep satisfaction.
Yeah.
Very good.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance and that by your unshakable resolve, you will attain full liberation from suffering sooner rather than later.